So by. The 20th of november.
Wearing fluorescent vision.
You know.
I came up to nimbin.
And so on but you know like i wrote.
I'm fluoresce division. When i
lived in sydney i was francesca.
But since moving up here.
I've decided that i like my name
to come back to me as a mantra.
And so i've called myself
virgin forest where.
I came to nimbin india lee
eighties for a three week holiday.
And found myself having my first
environmental arrest near mount nardi
protecting the forest environment
became an issue from
that point on it was about.
I didn't stay i actually had a very close
connection with kings cross for 10 years
and i was very fond of king's cross.
So i had a double paul in you
came up here when he was five
and fell in love with the
place. So he kept pulling back.
And so i've kept a very close
connection with people from the
time when there were environmental.
Activated with me
and so over the years of close
kept very close friendship
and it was normal feeling to come
and live up here after a while
when i got here a few years back to.
Help run the rainforest
information centre in lismore
and i was there for
about a year and a bit.
And then i moved to living
in teepees i've decided
that i had to live closer to the
ground closer to where mother
nature was suffering and.
And feeling what it is that we need to
do really you know just ask directly.
Your environment what needs to be done
and becomes really really very clear.
Certain things need to be done
and you do actually.
A love for freedom is my motivating force.
I like to live in an environment where
i'm not closed in my best expression
for
that is maybe the aboriginal way their guns
they had a gun you know which had no separation
between inside and outside.
And that is how i feel best.
That's how i feel i am living. To my
utmost. Rather than. Hiding away.
You know in a box.
You know in the house
and it feels like the perfect perfect
thing for me to be doing you know my body
loves the. I love dancing. I can.
It into singing i can do things
that come much more spontaneously if you
living in close connection with nature.
Knowing that the rainforest.
Yes i know that the rainforest.
Is the womb of life.
And there's only a few
remnants left on the planet.
Relation to what it was
not so very long ago.
So it is of the utmost importance
that we protect his remnant.
And live
when we live in close proximity with these
remnants live in total understanding of
our environment and in
total connection with it.
That is my spirit
and.
He actually had the straddle both worlds.
I lived in kings cross for a lot
of that time is only been here.
Proximately the same time as me.
Yeah yeah yeah ok ok sorry
that that has not experiences.
For i had my son emu.
Lived in kings cross for the
first 12 years of his life.
And you only had certain times
away from kings cross up here but
that was enough for him to
become an environmentalist
and he has gone to america on his own
twice to sing from coast to coast
environmental song and so he
keeps coming back to this place.
This place.
He loved his child
for education.
He un to preschool at rush does be
right on the water's edge because
that was the healthiest place for
him to be living in kings cross
and he loved it and he stayed there one
extra year so that he started school.
One year later and then he went to a
lara demonstration school. Which was.
A school in the richmond
suburbs again and.
It had a good effect on a mere india had
three male teachers through his primary
school
and he was able to relate for many hours a
day with a male which was great because
he was being brought up by me alone. And.
When he left when he left sydney at the
age of 12 in your retired schooling.
He'd made it to vaucluse boys high
but we just went for the merged
and he didn't emerge again tried one
term at high school when he was 15
and he didn't find it very inspiring.
So he went on the helen caldicott.
Bandwagon he used to sing
when she spoke in her election campaign
and that's what he's chosen to do.
He's just musician expressing
what's happening around.
People's.
Because his education is so far ahead
of anything that the education system
can possibly provide that it just.
It just defies all curricula.
Yeah.
You know. No there isn't but you.
And a lot of people.
In nimbin you find when
you dance with opinions
and people and don't exchange any words
you feel such high regard for them.
You feel such a powerful bonding and then
when you actually do exchange
words they're mostly good words
and people have feelings for one another.
They're recognizing each other's right
to exist and credibly and tolerant
and. Have a trifle less fear
than most people out there.
I like that.
Because.
How hard he was my first connection and
mountain out is just so beautiful.
The forest in there is just so magnificent
and my first connection with this
place was i stayed in a wooden dome.
It was like a small cathedral
just so beautiful so well placed
and filled with love and feeling. No.
Great plains.
This couldn't help
but live as an icon my in my living in
sydney i could always look back to this
and say this is this
one significant for
the forest is for me.
Letting go of thinking of myself
as the centre of the universe
and just becoming part of an
amazing array of creatures
plants smell this birdsong
lizards snake.
I just love being here.
Yes.
Sometimes i walk along metres
through the night with no moon
and i just walk through this
truly magical place who.
You know.
Is a kind of i think the religious
would call it a calling.
For me is just there's in.
You're down there is a he's going
down to the waterhole i'd say.
Yes it's good. It's.
A taking responsibility
and enjoying your life enjoying your life.
Doing things that you know you should
be doing and getting a lot of joy
and creative out of the creativity of i'm
doing a little permaculture hillside
with bush food.
And i'm evil damn at the bottom.
With frogs on every night like
an amphitheatre these frogs.
About 10 varieties just to
sing years of night for
and the kind of thing
that you can only have if you really love
and you're prepared to protect basically
so that's the attitude i have
heard.
I'm still on the dole. You know and.
I give massages twice a week.
Mondays and fridays in i do.
Something from esoteric
knowledge of osteopathy.
And she has to
and i use my entire body for
delivery my feet my arms my elbows.
And i bring a lot of structural
change in people's bodies.
And i really enjoy doing that.
I'm more concerned with moving
away from the attitude of.
Money being really important.
I'm more concerned with people actually
prove starting to produce food.
Produce their own food
that i think is more central
to focus upon you know.
Food production
and able to sustain yourself as
it's been a rule subsidy
most certainly yes.
Can you can i start again.
Yes you know the goal is to create a rule
subsidy and give people an
opportunity to branch out
and start something totally fresh a new
and that's the promise of aquarius
aquarius is a promise of fresh approach to
things.
And that's what the festival is
going to be showing it has to show
that otherwise there's absolutely no hope
but it has to be a new way of doing things
and we've had so many wars in close
connection with one another.
We haven't had a new resting period
between generations in peace.
So our brains are a bit
scrambled if you go to the edge
and you need to kill you need at least four
generations to recover press psyche to
recover. So if we can't find health
and well-being in the rainforest.
We're not going to find it anywhere.
So you know people say.
Best. Yeah.
We have to drop of a hat.
We celebrate celebrate
anything and everything and.
We have minister of the cultural affairs
and he ensures a healthy number
of dancers get togethers
and places for display.
Yes.
Yes we're kind of here together.
And we want to have a good time.
Yeah. This is such a beautiful planet.
It's such a mistake to have anything
else other than a very good time.